[Musique]
mais
une session particulière aujourd'hui je
vais rencontrer huit fitness france 2018
et 2019 cali baradji qui nous vient tout
droit de voisins-le-bretonneux bourganel
comment on fait pour devenir miss
fitness france est là pour devenir miss
fitness france déjà c'est de
l'entraînement je m'entraîne beaucoup il
faut être bon temps aux jeunes à peu
près 30 heures par semaine auteurs
beaucourt et d'entraînement et donc
c'est du cardio et de la musculation il
faut coupler les deux pour être la miss
fitness il faut avoir un profil assez
complet et c'est quoi le programme
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va je vous ai prévu pas
mal de choses
on va tester mon entraînement à moi mais
avant va s'échauffer bien sûr c'est
parti je vais me changer c'est parti et
après on pas trop sérieuse c'est parti
[Musique]
j'ai un peu peur parce que kddi a l'air
sûr motivé en tout cas pour me faire
souffrir
on va voir ce que ça donne mais
l'optimiste rover toujours quoique
cardiaque qui paraît il faut pas de
cardiaque apparemment donc qu attirer le
suis pas je me suis pas mal guerrier
bien ça passe en mode koh lanta colonnes
[Rires]
[Musique]
bravo ça va m'aider à le cardio super
commence à monter chez au top
du coup on va commencer par réchauffer
les cuisses
donc on va faire des squats 200 emplois
et a contraint des quads avec pour
beaucoup le mot simple squat simple tu
des temps
et tu montes ça va ça va ça va très bien
ça fait 3
4 c'est perturbant
c'est ça va pour l'instant 7 et 10
[Musique]
ici
on va faire un petit peu de peau donc on
commence par des pompes aussi sur la
botte
ou tu vas faire 5
donc là c'est le moment que j'appréhende
le plus un vraiment dans cette session
est apparemment calissons sortent très
bien
moi j'adore faire des pompes tout le
monde a à a
allez
1 ouais 2
pourquoi pas
oka encore une 4
parce que tu fais tous les jours
ah oui tous les jours je fais des
fonctions obligé combien minimum
je me réveille 10 puis dans la journée
elle se creuser quelques minutes ils ont
évidemment non sans nuire dans une année
pas de boire de l'eau comme angers ont
toutes leur pain on fait des pompes
[Musique]
oui
alors ouais
allez oui
[Musique]
ouah après une séance à votre caddie on
voit que tout de suite ça porte ses
fruits
voilà maintenant on va dire que j'arrive
à faire des tractions assez facilement